hunting down Easter eggs is more fun
with a friend so don't do it by yourself
yeah I'm not stupid of that too easy the
film opens on hans golden dice which we
first saw hanging up in the Millennium
Falcon's cockpit in a new hope they
became a symbol of his memory and
possible gambling addiction for both
Luke and Leia in the last Jedi Han
passes some fellow hard-working orphans
on planet Corellia who discussed how
many portions they're earning that day
this is the same cruel barter system
used at the scrapyard where Ray works
and the force awakens why is it so awful
for orphans in the Star Wars universe
it's like Annie with blasters out there
soon Han and his new pal Kira are
exiting Corellia making their escape
through coronet spaceport which was a
key location in the Star Wars MMORPG The
Old Republic once inside the spaceport
check out the helmets being worn by the
Imperial Guards we've seen them before
onboard the Death Star there may be a
bit too pointy to be practical but
intimidating also on the soundtrack they
play a snippet of John Williams Imperial
March in here first heard back and the
Empire Strikes Back you know the one I'm
talking about we can't play it here
we'll get sued Keira mentions her
concern that once they leave Corellia
they could be kidnapped by the Hutt
cartel this is one of several shout outs
to Jabba and his criminal enterprise
during the film most notably Hans new
pal Beckett talks about going to
Tatooine to smuggle for the Hutt's an
idea han borrows at the end of the film
we don't get to see Jabba at least until
George Lucas buys back Lucas films recut
these and re-releases them with new
special effects as special editions but
first Han joins the Empire really Becket
impersonating his captain has Han thrown
into a pit and fed to the Beast it turns
out to be Chewbacca but the whole scene
has shades of the rancor pit from
Jabba's palace in Return of the Jedi
and don't worry because spoiler alert
they wind up becoming friends also
Becket provides Han with his iconic
blaster so it all works out in the end
Ryo and alien on Becket's crew
recommends attending
my knock roast as they prepare for their
big score these are those winged rubbery
bat-like creatures with the suction cups
that Han Leia and Chewie encountered
inside that giant worm in the asteroid
field and Empire Strikes Back member
Empire Strikes Back I member soon enough
the heist is underway and Beckett's team
must contend not only with space pirates
always a concern but imperial probe
droids these are the same kind we saw
shouting for the rebel base on Hoth
these are the upgraded badass models
though the Hoth ones get taken out
pretty quick finally han meets his
lifelong pal Lando Calrissian over a
game of sabacc as Lando Donald Glover
pronounces Hans name as han instead of
Han the same way Billy Dee Williams used
to do it from the original trilogy han
corrects him but it doesn't stick so
he's been doing it intentionally to
annoy his friend over all these years
what a guy around this same time Lando
asks Han you have any idea what it's
like to live with a price on your head
of course this will one day be Huns very
dilemma as he's heavily indebted to
Jabba the Hutt and on the run from
bounty hunters when we meet him in a new
hope once the crew arrives on Kessel
Lando tells Han that he thinks mining
colonies are the worst kind of ironic as
when we meet him in Empire Strikes Back
he's managing the gas mining colony on
Cloud City he seems like he likes it
okay his capes are still jaunty maybe he
just changed his mind talking to Beckett
Lando thanks him for taking out a bounty
hunter named Aurra sing this is not just
some random name she had a small role in
the Phantom Menace and was a regular on
the TV series the Clone Wars the crew
needs to track down a valuable fuel
known as Co axiom and Kira mentions they
could potentially find some unscary this
was the beach planet from rogue one that
also serves as an Imperial base pretty
dangerous to go there I don't recommend
it last time it didn't work out great
during their mission on Kessel han
suggests that Lando is full of bantha
crap these are those large hairy horned
elephant looking animals that we saw in
Tatooine and a new hope they're the ones
that have that blue mill
that young Luke enjoyed because he's a
disturbed individual who's fixated on
milk from disgusting looking animals its
cannon at this point once onboard the
Falcon Beckett and Chewie played to
Jarek the 3d hologram chess game Luke
plays the same game against Chewie in a
new hope and his advise to let the
Wookiee win lest he gets his arms pulled
off and wouldn't you know else we're in
solo we actually do see Chewbacca pull a
guy's arms off reference is clear
terrific okay so the crew gets to Kessel
to pull off their second big heist of
the movie Beckett hides his face behind
a mask that should look familiar
it's the same one Lando wears when he's
undercover at Jabba's palace in Return
of the Jedi though Kessel plan itself is
actually pretty similar to Luke's plan
when he's saving han access the bases
guards and prisoners before sneaking off
to take care of your actual mission one
difference han says he has a good
feeling about this it's usually the
other way around it's not the only
direct dialogue callback before they
part ways Lando tells Han I hate you and
he responds I know this recalls his
final exchange with Leia before being
frozen in carbonite
Hans final showdown with Beckett is also
steeped in Star Wars tradition Han
notably fires first before Beckett has a
chance to shoot him a loving nod to the
controversy over Han shooting first at
Greedo in a new hope we've almost made
to the end I swear but a lot of
characters and actors from Star Wars
past show their faces in solo and we
just gotta shout them out don't want to
be disrespectful most surprisingly Kara
reveals she's been evil all along by
taking a Skype call with a certain Darth
Maul now it looked like he died way back
in the Phantom Menace days which was set
long before the action of solo but TVs
Clone Wars revealed that he miraculously
survived and spent 10 years in exile
without his memories before returning to
seek his revenge and the movie Maul is
played by Sam Witwer
the same actor who provides Darth Maul's
voice on Clone Wars
also if the wookie that Chewbacca
rescued on Kessel tuck looked familiar
well that's weird because he's in an
elaborate costume that covers his face
but you'd be right if you guessed that
he was played by Anthony Daniels c-3po
in the other Star Wars films at least
one member of the proto rebellion on
Saverin should look familiar
weasal was played by Warwick Davis who
memorably played wicket the Ewok in
Return of the Jedi and the title
character willow from Ron Howard's
eighties fantasy movie of the same name
but this was actually the second Star
Wars film to feature this specific
character weasel was also in the crowd
for the big pod race in the Phantom
Menace that guy running the droid cage
matches you guessed it actor Clint
Howard Ron Howard's brother who appears
in most of his movies finally we get a
few shots of a gnk power droid
participating in l33 seven's droid
rebellion these droids known as gonk
because of the sound they emit have been
with the series since the very very
beginning debuting all the way back in a
new hope you guys remember when we did
that solo video and rounded up all those
things you remembered from the early
Star Wars films now is awesome
want to feel old that was five years ago
this week let us know your favorite solo
memories in the comments below
you